ميدان قال الجيش الاوكراني انه افشل هجمات
للقوات الروسيه في بخبوت وفي افديفكا
ومارينكا في شرق اوكرانيا
للجيش الروسيشنها على مدن واتجمعات سكنيه
خاضعه لسيطرته في مقاطعه لوكانسكا في شرقي
اوكرانيا وفي مقاطعه زاكولوجيا في جنوب
افريقيا
للقوات الروسيه على اكثر من محور واشاره
الى القوات الروسيه قصر الفتى البنيه
التحتيه المدنيه في 11 منطقه وبلده في
ذكرى ودمر القصف ما لا يقل عن 18 منزلا في
المناطق المستهدفه
ينضم الينا من كرامات تورسك مراسل الجزيره
عمر الحارث
مدنيه متلاحقه الخبر الميداني الابرز وما
تقوله القوات الاوكرانيه بانها افشلت
محاولات للهجوم على مناطق سكنيه هذه
الهجمات الروسيه ما الذي يجري كمارسته
مرحبا
قصف مكثف على كل من
اكرامتوسعه هذه المدن الرئيسيه في مقاطعه
دونيت قبل قليل
من قبل القوات الروسيه بالفعل كما ذكرتم
الحدث
الامرزال هذه المحاولات المستمره والتي
تعلن عنها السلطات الاوكرانيه في سواء في
محاورما او حتى في محوري منها حتى في
مدينه باخ متانه التي وصفت في وقت سابق
بانها اكثر النقاط سخونه قبل قليل الاغتس
سابق ايضا كان هناك
الذي تحدث عن هذه عن هذه همم
وصفه ايضا ان جبهه تكريمنا هي هي الاخرى
واحده من الجبهات العنيفه بين جانبين وقال
ان الخطوط الدفاعيه اللي هي القوات
الروسيه هناك
في وضع الحرج وقال مره اخرى ان انهيار دي
الخطوط الدفاعيه سيدرك عنده الروس ان
خطوطهم الدفاعيه في كامل هذا الشريط
المنتدى على نحو 60 كيلومترا لي ستكون
مهدده من قبل الجيش الاوكراني في بخمض
ايضا كان هناك تصريح لافتا المتحدث باسم
قياده المنطقه الشرقيه
في الجيش الاوكراني قال فيه ان القوات
الاوكراني الى القوات الروسيه الان غيرت
نمط قتلها تحت وطات الخسائر التي تبنى بها
منذ عده اسابيع وقال ان الان مجموعه انها
تقدر على شكل مجموعات قليله تتراوح بين
ثمانيه وعشره مقاتلين فقط بعد ان كان
القتال همم على شكل كتائب او ارتال تتقدم
من عده محاور وقال لها مره اخرى انها
خسائر كبيره في صفوف القوات اتفاجنر وهذا
ربما سيقودها الى سياق او سيناريو مشابهه
لما حدث في مدينه خلصن حين اضطرت هذه
القوات بالانسحاب هذا مره اخرى وفقا
لروايه الاوكرانيه ايضا حاكم مقاطعه همم
دنيا وتحدث عن سقوط جرحى في قصف روسي على
مناطق مختلفه في المقاطع في زبريجه ايضا
همم المنطقه الجنوبيه المعارك هناك همم
يبدو انها ستاخذ شكلا اعنف وفقا لما
تصريحات القوات الاوكرانيه تتحدث عن
رشودنا عسكريا في تلك المنطقه قد تكمل
تحديدا وايضا الحشود روسيه مشابهه تتجمع
في مدينه ميليتبول الاستراتيجيه في اعداد
المقاطعه
مراسل الجزيره عمر الحاج شكرا جزيلا لك